et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois aux mairies le président cf cgc
bonsoir françois om-lille merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on vient d'entendre le
medef et la cfdt favorable à la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
salariés au contact du public cet appel
solennel est ce qu'il est légitime selon
vous est ce que ces syndicats sont dans
leur rôle
c'est pas tellement à moi de définir
très exactement quel est le rôle d'une
organisation syndicale en tant que tel
moi je je connais le mien je ne vais pas
critiquer les prises de position que
prenne mes collègues pour ce qui
concerne cfe cgc de position finalement
elle est relativement simple et elle et
de dire
de deux choses l'une soit il est
nécessaire de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour des raisons qu'on était
un peu exposé un dans votre reportage et
des raisons qui sont commentées par
ailleurs et à ce moment là le
gouvernement doit le faire c'est pas le
seul vaccin qui serait obligatoire il y
en a d'autres mais c'est pas à moi de
dire s'il faut le rendre obligatoire ou
pas après par ailleurs nous on est
intervenu je suis intervenu au nom de
mon organisation sur la question de la
vaccination de façon à travailler avec
le gouvernement sur les moyens à mettre
en place pour rendre pour faciliter la
vaccination dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui il y a
on le sait la vaccination contre la
grippe qui fonctionne plutôt bien qu'ils
aient mis à disposition dans les
services de santé au travail c'est un
moyen assez pratique assez efficace de
d'augmenter le niveau de vaccination sur
tel ou tel sujet sur telle ou telle
maladie donc sur la question de la
vaccination contre le coc vide tout ce
qui peut être mis en oeuvre pour
faciliter cette vaccination dans le
cadre du travail
eh bien nous on soutient ces
dispositions là après on répondra très
précisément avec votre à votre question
moi je n'ai pas à donner mon avis sur le
fait qu'il faut ou non la rendre
obligatoire ce pas mon sujet alors ce
que disent ces syndicats tout de même
ces voix là c'est notre seule chance en
substance un de faire repartir
l'économie et donc les entreprises
savent où partager tout de même ce
diagnostic son ensemble ou piégées et
vous dire à vous voyez vous voulez l'arn
obligatoire mais en gros on a une pente
bien faire pour l'économie est ce qu'on
doit penser ainsi
à écouter et là encore vous savez c'est
un sujet un peu délicate sur lequel
beaucoup de gens se sont exprimés à
plusieurs reprises en n'ayant pas
forcément les compétences nous nous dans
une organisation syndicale on n'a pas de
compétence passive assez d'experts sur
les questions sanitaires
ce que je sais c'est que la reprise
économique par contre effectivement elle
est là il faut la soutenir par tout un
tas de dispositions on à demain ce
sommet à l'elysée où effectivement on va
aborder un certain nombre de sujets qui
sont dans l'ordre du jour et qui sont
relatifs à la question du redémarrage
économique des moyens qu'il faut mettre
en place qui sont des moyens financiers
par ailleurs qui peuvent être des moyens
d'organisation de façon à porter la
reprise et c'est vrai qu'il serait
dommage moi juste d'accord avec ça il
serait dommage de de se retrouver
confronté à une quatrième vague une
troisième quatrième et cinquième vague
moi j'ai fait confiance dans les
services sanitaires de mon pays j'espère
que ils font tout ce qu'il faut pour
justement l'anticiper l'esprit civique
est quand même relativement important et
il est clair que si on arrive à bien se
prémunir contre
une éventuelle quatrième vague et bien
les conditions économiques sont bien
entendu bien meilleure pour pouvoir
redémarrer du bon pied et retrouvé le
niveau de croissance et d'activité
économique en a perdu il ya 18 mois et
qui aujourd'hui effectivement nous nous
préoccupons là on parlait des salariés a
notamment en contact du public il ya
évidemment le débat sur la vaccination
obligatoire des des soignants et avant
de faire réagir je voudrais vous faire
écouter philippe martinez secrétaire
général de la cgt qui lui pour le coup
c'est s'est clairement prononcée je ne
suis pas favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants il vaut mieux
convaincre plutôt que contraindre
discuter plutôt que d'imposer on ne peut
pas les montrer du doigt aujourd'hui
après les avoir applaudi toute l'année
dernière il ceci est valable pour
l'ensemble de la population
donc c'est vrai que beaucoup
d'observateurs de médecins parlent de
faute morale quand on ne se fait pas
vacciner conte et soignant on a eu des
invités de ce différend syndicalistes de
soignants nous dire nous nous sommes
contraints à l'instar d'ailleurs de
philippe martinez quelle est votre
position dans votre syndicat moi je
place jamais les débats sous l'angle de
la moralité on est dans un pays dans
lequel c'est la loi qui s'applique donc
soit la loi et les bonnes
soit la loi elle est pas mal et on la
change donc en l'occurrence si c'est
nécessaire pour des questions sanitaires
j'y reviens de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire et bien rendre la
obligatoire et il faut voir d'où on
vient quand même un ya 18 mois rappelez
vous il n'y avait pas de masque de
disponibles et on nous expliquait que
finalement le masque ce n'était pas
nécessaire c'était d'ailleurs au passage
les consignes de l'om et ça s'était très
clairement dit le ministre olivier
verrons nous le disaient les consignes
de l'eau msc le masque est réservé aux
soignants
il n'est pas nécessaire d'emporter pour
la population générale et on public
notamment en extérieur et on voit bien
que les choses changent elles évoluent
moi je ne fais de procès d'intention à
personne
on vit dans des conditions effectivement
précaire au sens où on est confronté à
des situations tout à fait nouvelle moi
je n'aime pas beaucoup si vous voulez
une société dans laquelle on est ambigu
dans laquelle on est floue où on
sollicite chez les gens d'être conforme
à une certaine forme de morale en fait
écouter dans l'organisation syndicale
elle intervient dans la sphère publique
dans l'espace public elle fait référence
à des valeurs nous on en a les valeurs
de l'encadrement la protection des gens
qui s'engagent dans leur carrière dans
leur entreprise
voilà tout ça est une certaine façon
palpable
après la question de savoir si c'est
bien ou si c'est mal mais je pense que
c'est un sujet un peu difficile sur
lequel il est un peu compliquée
d'afficher des certitudes
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'il y ait des
consignes qu'elles soient claires et que
surtout on met les moyens en place assez
hier à la disposition de tout le monde
les moyens nécessaires à affronter ses
consignes en fait c'est ça le sujet en
pleine pandémie
la question de la réforme des retraites
revient à un petit peu sur toutes les
lèvres c'est la dernière ligne droite
pour le quinquennat emmanuel macron vous
l'a souhaité non absolument pas non
seulement je le souhaite pas mais je
trouve ce débat un peu inquiets temple
tout vous dire moi je pense que la
retraite c'est un sujet beaucoup trop
sérieux beaucoup trop grave qui concerne
tout le monde et qu'on ne peut pas comme
ça le confier à une petite cellule de
communicants qui prépare telle ou telle
campagne électorale c'est devenu un
objet politique et ben moi je conteste
ça la retraite c'est un système dans
lequel il ya des opérateurs des
opérateurs financiers ya des gens qui
travaillent dans les conseils et venir
nous dire aujourd'hui la retraite est en
danger catastrophique et c'est faut
absolument faire une réforme
moi je dis que c'est faux parce que
on a les éléments objectifs qui nous
permettent d'affirmer c'est dans le
d'ailleurs le dernier rapport du conseil
d'orientation des retraites
on a les éléments objectifs qui nous
permettent de dire que les trajectoires
qui permettent d'anticiper les vagues
démographiques sont toujours respectés
malgré la crise est donc absolument pas
d'urgence à démonter il faut affronter
la crise est bien là crise elle a
impacté toute l'économie a impacté les
comptes sociaux il n'y a pas de raison
tout d'un coup de prendre pan de panique
et de faire des bêtises sur la retraite
c'est la première chose
et la deuxième chose j'entends dire oui
il faut faire la réforme des retraites
parce qu'après quand on se présente à
une élection qui que ce soit c'est les
l'image de dire voilà j'ai fait la
refais la réforme j'ai eu du courage
bah écoute et non moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça c'est quoi cette idée
ont fait la réforme n'importe laquelle
pour pouvoir dire j'ai fait une réforme
non c'est pas sérieux une société
effectivement doit en permanence
s'adapter et donc pour cela elle doit se
réformer mais par rapport à des
paramètres qui sont identifiables et on
ne doit pas comme ça cole porter un peu
des idées catastrophique faire peur aux
gens pour pouvoir faire passer à la va
vite des réformes qui n'ont pas d'effets
positifs moi je veux rappeler pour finir
que le système de retraite par
répartition il sera en forme en
permanence depuis 1993 date de la
première réforme vraiment structurantes
pour affronter la vague démographique du
baby-boom devenu le petit bout mais il
ya eu à peu près six ou sept train de
réformes relativement importante et que
de toute façon les retraites en tendance
quelqu'un qui part en retraite
aujourd'hui il a déjà une retraite d'un
niveau inférieur à celle qu'elle était
il ya 10 ans où il ya 20 ans et donc les
adaptations elles ont été faites il ya
des trajectoires les trajectoires qui se
base sur des indicateurs économiques sur
des indicateurs démographiques c'est le
premier ordre et il n'y a absolument
aucune urgence exactement la première
phrase du corps il n'y a pas d'urgence à
réformer un système qui est conforme aux
projections que l'on avait avant la
crise
merci beaucoup françois bélisle
président cfe cgc d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france ce soir